what are the first few things you do
when you start making a movie can you
take us through like the first month
yeah if it's a script that I did not
write the first step would be you know
definitely making sure I understand the
script and you know I think the process
of making a film and making any film
project is fairly similar it always
starts with a script and making sure
that I feel it like that's important to
me that it kind of makes my heart beat a
little bit faster when I read it so if I
didn't write it like smoothing out some
of these character transitions you know
finding it's important to find themes
that mean something to me even if it's a
movie about time travel like what's what
makes me you know like I know when
Zemeckis did Back to the Future like the
idea of hanging it he wondered if he
what it would be like to hang out with
his dad in high school and if he'd like
him that's where that came from and
that's what got him up in the morning
that's what really made him connect to
this story right and that's what made
that film so great so I think that's
really an important that what's gonna
carry you through the whole movie it's
finding that picking your crew then
would be like a next big like you need
to find your creative partners I like to
you know and of course your cast I like
to cast my crew as well having good
attitudes and good professionals around
me is very important I like to pick
people who were better than me
you know I don't want to DP that I'm
better than I'd rather have someone who
pushes me and who's not a diva
you know sets or pressure cookers it's
hard and there will be days where you
were self will come out you want good
people even though they'll so they may
snap when the hour is late they're still
good people at the end of the day and
you're okay together so that's important
like I really carefully picked those
crew people then I'll start as soon as I
can on I like the storyboard I like to
really know shots specifically at a
minimum at least a shot a list of things
because your ad is gonna want that I
have found that you cannot prepare
enough if the scene is complex like for
example with suppression the room
changes shape throughout the story
so I actually built miniatures of the
sets with little army men and in their
relation to the size of the set so that
I can really understand and kind of get
my head around the physicality that
we're working with I'm doing a Star Wars
fan film we're shooting next week I did
the same thing like we had a bunch of
stormtroopers and we have a couple
characters I got little action figures
so I could take this fight scene and map
it out like and move the characters
around just to see the geometry of what
we're playing with that's so helpful for
the actors for the stunt coordinator for
the cinematographer to go oh right I see
like everything you can do to help the
rest of the crew understand what you're
doing better so storyboards mood boards
finding video clips showing everyone
like see this scene this is a scene that
I like and I'm trying to emulate see the
colors and the way they splash in the
back well that helps so much speeds the
process way up because the worst thing
to do the killer of creativity is
endless explaining onset of what you're
trying to achieve and no one
understanding it that's really
frustrating and and slows you down
so yeah I'm big on storyboards I love
doing those and and I really like the
action figures because it's a lot of fun
now that said there are some things you
can't plan for which I'll just
acknowledge that going in I'll try to
get some general parameters for example
like a say a big dialogue scene where
it's two characters whatever in a living
room I know that I may hit certain beats
I'm a map out like I know that at this
point didn't be face to face and they're
really angry but I don't want them
looking at each other at this point
so I might do some of those but then on
set I'll just kind of organically try to
figure it out as we go
that comes also with the preparation
because you need to plan for that time
to work with the actors for that so like
when you get to set to make sure your ad
understands like I need I need 20
minutes or an hour to walk through the
scene with the actors just so everyone
knows what's going on I think yeah so
once I have all that done meeting with
the department heads is key it's kind of
surprised to me how often times that
does not happen but meeting with your
production designer you DP your guy yeah
gaffers sometimes can be helpful they're
good for the location scout but you know
wardrobe hair and make all those people
the producers so and it go through line
by line on the script have the actors
there and read the lines if you can so
then if there's any questions everybody
knows the answers like because things
they'll start asking you questions that
you never real all right yeah no it says
it's a it's a pistol it's not a rifle
it's a pistol really I always thought it
was a rifle those things will come up if
you like don't just gloss over scene
read through it cuz you know someone has
question raise your hand that's so
important yeah and the sooner on don't
do that days before do that at least a
week couple of weeks before so they have
time to go shop if they need to or
whatever yeah and I personally like to
be physically fit for these things cuz
it's also physically hard to do shooting
like to take time for myself like I like
to get massages while I'm working
not while I'm working like in between
like once a week we're leading up
because it's you know the stress will
make you find out so now let's do a lot
of yoga so like lots of yoga and prep
physically for it eat very healthy
leading up try to get as much rest as I
can that's important too because it will
push you you may end up sick by the end
it happens a lot yeah those those are
the main things I would do and again you
can't prepare enough for these things
there'll always be questions you said it
a thousand times and people are gonna go
I don't understand it that just happens
so you actually showed the crew these
action figures sometimes yeah and and
just how like from from this like almost
looking down like this
different perspective like as 3d sort of
things if there's not for every single
scene but for certain scenarios yes
absolutely
yeah for action scenes it's really
important like it's especially because
our complex multi person seeing the
suppression it was necessary so that we
could all understand the size of this
room in the shape and what the actors
gonna have to be dealing with you know
because that that'll adjust the lighting
like okay the sets now like this and
like this
gaffer can look at then go oh I'm gonna
have to rebuild the grid for that okay
that means from day one to day two I got
a chain okay okay good to know that you
know so that that's really helpful
you're just you're basically trying to
paint as big clear a picture for
everyone as possible and then with the
corporate videos I'm sure it's a little
bit of a different approach or maybe
it's the same but then you're coming
into someone's company and you're that
guy and everyone's like oh there's a
director oh my god you know and but
you're coming into their world their
sets kind of already built yeah I mean
it's very very similar and this is why I
think corporate is such a good practice
because it's the same muscle same exact
thing it doesn't matter what's your
sheeting and and in some ways it's more
important that they understand what
you're getting you don't want them to be
surprised at the thing at the end you
know oh I did primary colors and you
just gave me a contrast II dark moody
thing you know you don't want that
that's bad they'll never hire you again
if that happens so yeah being very very
clear showing pictures all of that how
can I just end up a client meeting today
where we discussed colors very
specifically the scripting that I sent
them they said whoa want can you make it
brighter even in the description of the
story like we want to make sure that
when we see a kid we don't want to see
kids sick in a hospital bed we want to
see them on a playground it's good to
know good to know bright colors so yeah
very clear I don't necessarily have to
go so far as having department head
meeting on some of those things because
some of them are
simple but definitely with your group of
clients whatever it is that's important
you